[Applause]
okayyyy so yeah my name is Ruben sauce
better and here today to speak about
fantasy machines which for those of you
they've been here on Wednesday you
probably been on David talk about fancy
machines it is related it's not the same
hopefully at the end of my talk you will
have more insight and feel empowered
enough to try for your own before
starting you see we have this picture
and at the end I'm gonna ask you if any
on the audience know what it is don't
answer now it's gonna be at the end
because the talk is going to give you
some clues about it I'm a JavaScript
hacker I'm working as an independent
contractor so if you need something just
pick me out and I love capybaras is
majestic and excellent friendly shaped
animal if you don't know about him just
please check out I always find someone
in the audience that agree with me with
it animal is the biggest rodent in the
world and in Venezuela they eat eat it
and another thing yeah another thing is
that I just want to share with you this
special moment because you see this
t-shirt this t-shirt is from the 2015
edition of the Jesus come for the base
it was my first conference ever also my
first business travel outside of my
country and I remember being there it
was super exciting it was when I was
like starting ending being a junior
developer and it was mind-blowing
experience and I remember being there
I'm feeling like man if ever I need I
have the sense to give back something to
a community I went to speak in that
conference so I'm here four years later
dreama chief thank you that's it no so
thank you the organizer to the
organization for that
that's definitely well anyway going to a
topic actually David he was hearing
Wednesday he said this develop user
interfaces is not easy in the reactor
alley in 2017 and it was I think this is
was this this thought of him was like
kind of the beginning or the find steam
machines coming back to the UI scene and
fronting and so on and there is
explanation for that first
machines is a concept that started like
in the late 60s so it's super all
actually probably you hear about finding
machines when you were studying software
engineer in the university or something
like that it's very useful if you want
to reason about logics and they kind of
stuff but probably you never use it in
production like never even I don't know
in your hobby or pet project and that's
basically because for so long we were
doing front-ends that they were let's
call it simple right it was a static
HTML with some CSS or then we have I
don't know PHP with tweaked rendering
engine templates whatever you get it you
know what it means speaking about but
now we're doing very complex foreign
applications and these run applications
as you know for example yesterday's
explained soorma and Jake well you have
web packs and roll ups and plugins and
configurations and performance and
latencies and different assets and
caching is super complex we're reaching
upon a point where we're moving a lot of
business logics and responsibilities to
a foreign applications and what does the
mean is that we're generating a lot of
box rest conditions and the sorry side
effects and so on and we find that our
UI it's maybe are not perfect our using
our users follow our instructions
blindly and this generates even even
more VAX we have side effects and rest
condition for example this is a race
condition against the disk like do you
think if I press cancel button this is
going to stop no it won't stop never
like this is the cancel button is just
like a psychology thingy so you can
smash it and release your anger it's
only for that oh that one which is also
I hate that one like personally I
hate this one this is also like
when you want to share something on an
Android device and then it suddenly pops
up your your recent chats and then you
send a link to someone else I just hated
this is also a race condition in this
case against the network so the problem
is that we're doing the fancy fur
this is the first concert that we need
to understand defensive programming is
basically when what we're calling
something we find an issue and then we
straightaway try to fix that issue we've
done
as David said we don't plan ahead so
let's see an example that probably all
of you have experienced at some point in
the past we're making a call
this is react but don't don't really
follow the the code it's just to
exemplify so we're making a call to fix
the user and then we render the name and
then we also want at some point to have
a lull instead right because I mean if I
don't know network is slow we don't when
the user to stay there turning on a
blank screen and then came out so they
Pio and say it's a but something can be
read we need some error state and
explain the user what happens and
recover and make against the call so we
start having these conditionals that
render different things also different
catches depending on what happens it's a
long request so maybe we need to cancel
at some points it has to be possible
that you cancel so if you look closely
while we're saying in this code like if
you pay enough attention it's a shape
okay and why why is a so this is
this is really important because usually
we start thinking about normalcy
architecture if with you excitement on
architecture this is not this won't
happen or DDD or whatever is insourcing
no no it's neither the technology like
if you just react or angular or bu or
circular even change technology is not
related to that is neither the patterns
I don't know if you are doing
programming or not your code could be
easier to understand or maintain but you
are not addressing this kind of issues
and actually that's why you are feeling
that situation over and over for always
right it doesn't matter the project you
are the company you are working with or
the team you are working with you are
running to the situation every time the
problem is the approach
defensive programming is also known as
bottom-up approach which is basically
that we're facing one problem at a time
every time the problem like reaches
right so when we are doing bottom-up
approaches is difficult for us to
understand at the end what's the code is
difficult to maintain is difficult to
make changes there is out of its cases
that we are not considering there is
sort of mutation that we are starting to
do it's really easy I'm prone to start
doing some hacks around the code which
is no good it's also difficult to test
of course if you don't understand
something it's going to be difficult to
test also our code is not going to be
pure most of the times because with
those mutations well and we have these
complex setups for testing I have seen
projects small projects with ensign
configurations longer than the actual
project and I'm not joking this is
something I've seen which is obviously a
cough the smell is difficult in Haines
obviously if you can test something it's
also like dangerous thing hence you
don't know if the testing is working it
generates out of bugs and gonna make
this I mean like a lot a lot of facts
right we don't want a spaghetti code in
case you don't notice we have a lot of
posters around this venue that say so
and refactoring is also going to be very
difficult because we don't know what
exactly we have to change so at the end
you are gonna feel like this pooch
reminder that you are just fixing one
fire after the other and you're more
like a fireman rather than a developer
so what's the solution
so the top-down approach which actually
makes a lot of sense um the top-down
approach is basically that you have this
abstract concept and bu of your product
and every time you have a problem you go
back to that abstract definition and
then analyze it from then and later on
you implement it you stop reacting
that's a pun and and basically how does
this looks because so far everything is
super abstract it looks like that it's a
user flow or a diagram or whatever so
this is a
seen on a blog or whatever what you have
like different states and transitions
and you can be in the landing page and
then you move to block but please and
then from that you can click go to a
blog whatever and then for example is
interesting that the definition here
that at the very right have the contact
form and you see two are responding the
contact form that means that there is
only two ways to reach that page this is
what we are doing when we reason about
with a top-down approach from the
abstract point of view so if this is so
this is important because this is a
common language for humans we can
understand this as a developer's product
owners can understand these designers
can understand this our stakeholders can
understand this so if this is a human
language and we as developers basically
what we do is translate human language
the technical language of any kind then
find some machines technical language
first the machine is basically the
easiest and more logic implementation of
his user flows so what defines the
machine super easy it's deterministic
finds a machine or accept 30 minutes
find the state machine is akin to pull
not really this was me the first time as
the definition I first sometimes I read
some things and he could understand
anything so I asked one of my friends
who's math scientist to give me a hand
and basically I think it's easier if we
reason about in a language though I
guess we are understanding here which is
JavaScript so Sigma is the input
alphabet is basically a dictionary it
could be representing like that it's an
object with keys we had seen this before
the s is early stage the this is super
nos that you can represent that like
whatever you want in this case is an
object where the keys matches the
dictionary and then inside you have an
object with whatever you want it doesn't
matter what's inside is your state
definition so this will depend on your
business logics and your project
whatsoever S sub 0 is the initial state
okay easy the only important thing is
that it has to be part of the States
obviously and then Delta is a transition
is how you move from one state to the
other in this example for example the
state is defined which means that one
state only half a transition but another
state there is no multiple states
otherwise we will be doing something
like machine from the current state I
give you an action and then you give me
back what's going to be the next day and
there is a fine state machine that's it
so the thing on the top is our like very
easy simple short fine state machine
this will be a turnstile like in the
underground right you know we have this
machine that moves from lock to unlock
initially it's locked because we don't
want the earthly word go for free and
then we have the transition to move from
one state to the other this is in these
cases in JavaScript it's an object in
Tepes clip could be a rapport or so in
c-sharp or in Python it's it's called a
tuple and in PHP in its be the call for
help
so way easier to reason about okay so so
far we understand more or less the math
concepts how does this looks in software
engineering so let's see the anatomy of
our example of a fetch request
so usually you represent the ladies
fancy machines you have initial state
most of the times it's either my friends
machine is doing nothing I have
different states so we so far we see as
subservient Ischl state and all these
states yes we have some events or
actions to move around the different
states and then we have the two stations
right you can be a needle after the
action fetch will move to fetching and
then there's two different actions and
may happen and we end up in two
different states this is something that
can be like improve and it could be like
super complex and then you move to state
charts words and the kind of stuff that
we are not going to look at that in this
topic because I only have 25 minutes but
definitely check it out later on that's
it we know how are the mathematical
definitions on the origin we know how
this looks like for us so for engineers
the only thing that we are missing
are the three key features of feinstein
machine first of all is deterministic
which basically means that it's
predictable and this is one of the most
important features of the finite state
machines and what gives you the benefit
of being bug free this basically means
that even the current state and an
action I can predict what's going to be
the next state and this is super
powerful because you won't find rabbit
holes or dead ends in your products
anymore since everything is going to be
defined is that how to get there is the
what's coming next is you can put your
hoops not as in react loops just like
normal hoops and actions and data values
everything goes because it's
deterministic
it's an automata which means it's a
predetermined sequence so another way of
written about this always happens in the
same single way always acts in the same
way let's say for example that the
easiest example is a semaphore right in
like in the streets you have this to the
right for the cars and pedestrians it
goes from red to green from green to
yellow and then integrate I think and we
want this to be always in that way we
want this to be an isolated system not
depending anything else city lights
don't depend usually on the cars or
pedestrians or whatsoever and we want
this to work always in the same way
because otherwise people will die this
is bad we don't want people that
basically and finally it's fine it and
maybe it's not the most important thing
is actually pretty obvious but this is
important because we also have to
infinity machines which are completely
different and it doesn't it's a
different topic but this is what makes
possible that the finest the machines
are this common language between non
technical and technical people because
we can do user flows and everything else
that we saw before
so basically science the machine is a
pure assistant I can only be in one of a
set of predefined stage this is me right
now actually it's me 10 months ago
because that was the first time I said
but it works there's all types of things
I see a lot of
poker faces but it's fine because they
think I'm going to be the first speaker
doing some demo because I believe I'd
like to live in danger so basically you
can see my demo now yes so this is the
application is very simple it's this
example that I show you before the
fetching things we fetch for users and
then we're under the name right and now
it's not working which is important I'm
gonna spell you why but you can see that
it start with the state IDO when they
want to fetch something you moves to
fetching and then you start searching
and for example the fetching state
doesn't have an action for fetch right
so this is reflected in the UI that you
cannot press the button again and this
is when you start seeing the benefits
and the back free feature of the file is
a machine from that point if you want to
know more move to the David talk of
honor of Wednesday because his was about
it
and how this does how this looks
can all you read it like in the end I
see positive feedback oh so basically
our machine is this thing here that's it
it's a simple JavaScript object as I
told you there is nothing else in this
case I'm not using any library or
nothing like that
I'm gonna share with you the code later
on so you can hide it around but I
wanted to implement something like very
nice and simple just using vanilla
JavaScript and react for rendering so
you can get all the concepts and don't
get viruses but any library but this
probably is something that I won't use
for production applications but the
concept of the machine being something
completely isolated and independent is
important so my machine has an initial
state has some states if you are in ego
you can move to fetching you get all all
all the things and then here's the
rendering right
I have a normal reactor plication
there's the thing as my main my takes
render from machine this is what the
title like but bear with me it works and
I've render different components
depending on the stage you are
everything is pretty obvious actually
it's super simple right
why this doesn't work in because we're
still missing one concept which is which
are the Commons the Commons is a thing
or concept of work to connect your is
like the look for you finds the machine
like you have to defines the machine
which contains your transition business
logics and so on and so forth maybe your
data whatever and then you want to plug
this to something like for example food
react so you can do whatever you want
with your friends the machine otherwise
is just a bunch of declarations the
commands is this thing that connects you
frenched the machine with the for
example the rendering service and it
also the wondered resistor the side
effects so the side effects is the
actually the the most important thing
and the most complex things to change
the machines because you probably have
this semaphore as we mentioned before
but the semaphore is doing nothing
that's why it's so easy but actually now
we have an application that I defined
that they want to move to wheedle to
fetching and then to success or failure
but they want to do something when this
is doing fetching in this case it wants
to fetch the user this is how you
connect you finds the machine when the
action is on fetching what's the action
or wait is this action we're tweaking
the action here so it's in my definition
that I say when you're in the state
fetching trigger the action fetching
difficult aiming and in here I'm
registering okay so in this case when
you listen to the fetching action do
this side effect and if you notice we
are fetching and then we are also doing
the transition here to move to the next
one okay this is this is how you connect
the parts so if we go back to the demo
hopefully no one no one is breaking my
Wi-Fi yeah it works cool
so please see and the cool part of these
is that you
cannot break it it doesn't matter if you
click licked like a madman here you
cannot break it because every state has
its own actions and different
propagations and so on so hopefully it's
clear what we see now yes the commands
which are the side effects manager which
is kind of the most important part and
actually if you feel like you like what
I'm telling you today and you go outside
to the while and look for some libraries
you will notice that most of the
libraries basically focus on that part
because it's the important one so well
I'm just sorry that's that's like that's
important thing what's the cool thing
that we saw so far is that we don't have
conditions remember our example and your
example in the render for example we
have this if the state is earlier than
rendered these otherwise vendor that if
I'm in a state fetching and you press
cancel then change the state and go back
those are all the conditions that will
generate bugs in your application but
when you're working with fancy machines
you do not have conditions are old what
we have is the for example in my
implementation is a switch case which
are not on well it's conditional that is
not I don't remember the name in flicks
operator I think it's an it wherever you
get it will have the conditions like
usually like an even an LS and depending
on that do so Yallah Yallah Yallah so
you can have freeze conditions also
remember the first examples and the face
the first gifts you don't run into the
kind of issues let's see also what we
have if you have a find a steam machine
like this one it's a bit clumsy to move
little silos my cursor now here it is so
what we have also see the rendering part
see thus those components right loading
user error main text everything and
getting them from here and this
component is imported from components
and is that file look at that because
basically here what we're doing is I'm
in an environment called web this is
just an example but I'm an environment
called web so give me my web components
since your business logic
actions data everything is the couple
this is that the world is the couple
from everything else you can just plug
and play whatever system you want here
you will say all you will say also know
this is react environment but maybe I
want to react environment when you're in
a very low latency a high latency
network for example as some explained
yesterday right why don't can you move
to different components and the end it
doesn't really matter your business
logic is completely isolated it will be
also a problem that we have the Metro a
native community which is quite big and
it's how to reduce components and logics
well just user finds the Machine and
here you say my environment is native so
give me my react needed components this
will work perfectly no issue at all
another option is to look at that from
the other way around and what does that
mean is that you can have your for
example react web application that
fetches you find the same machine to a
server don't loss did this JSON that
defines a machine and then everything
works so if you want to do and you go
have like your let's say for example our
registration for write all the
components are the same
everything is done by your design system
for example and then it's just about
even a pro turner will change a JSON
file to define a different transition
and this will be automatically applied
to all your clients which is super
powerful so what we saw right now is
that another benefit it was just a
couple which is super important thing
and one of the main benefits I try this
simple action in the company was working
before for any different we are web and
it works smoothly and then for me one of
the things that I liked the most is the
testing that's gonna show you this is
best we have around a 70% coverage what
yours you are not seeing it
sorry sorry yes sorry this is the test
ok there is around 70% coverage not 70
but close to that but the cool part is
not the coverage and that everything
passes the cool part is that this
all the testing that I have in my
application nothing else there is
absolutely no other file for testing
because remember that I told you is
deterministic and it's an automata that
means that you can just in this case for
example we are starting the our
application in different states of our
machine it's it important so it doesn't
matter what happened before if I'm in
the state failure
I don't need B my application to pass
through evil and fetching if I start on
error it's going to be error every time
so I can just do this well this is the
Uniting limitation but I can just go
through all the different states of my
friend state machine and do a snapshot
testing and you just don't believe me
watch it by yourself this is a snapshot
so basically what's doing is like you
are in needle so there is like the let's
do search you remember the application
before we are in fetching the eyes the
searching button success and you're so
far and so forth so this this is the
testing and finally the last part is
that I can break my application whatever
I want so that was the caution is it
okay you seen this nice so I can break
my application whatever they want like
and like for example here I guess this
works so good no so it's very difficult
because there is a lot of latency okay
this will work I guess if not excuse me
so yeah it's broken why because we
define in our application that is
something goes wrong you just basically
go to their or state it doesn't matter
like how this happens so we are just
throwing our I wrote like anyway
anywhere and this will break it is it
will go here for example this something
you can connect very easily and very
smoothly with the react bound ever
boundaries and it will be super smooth
the transitions so I don't know about
you but first time I try was like this
is magic
I really there is this there is these
two things for me at least
that are super good benefits first of
all you basically consider all the edge
cases corner cases and everything of
your application once you end up doing
this
user flow or diagram whatsoever this is
everything you got which is very useful
for you as a developer implementing it
but it's also very useful for your I
don't know how to call it and you're
just gonna give you an example so you
and your company something's broken pro
turner comes by and say hey this is not
working as expected and you start this
conversation oh no this is what you
asked me for you've been there yeah I
can see in your faces so now it's gonna
be like no see the diagram you didn't
define it so it's fine let's gonna fix
it and we all know what happened before
and what's the evolution and the second
part at least for me that I was really
impressed was the testing part because I
don't like to do testing and I don't
know a lot of people that really loves
doing testing is something that we do
because we know it's needed it's not
something that we do because we love it
it's basically like it eating healthy so
yes for the end I want to show you some
resources I'm I'm gonna share with you
the slides like in five minutes on
Twitter but if you have to check one
just please go to the ex State Library
from from David this is simply good and
well this is the book that David also
recommended the constructing the UA with
state charts it's a ton of the original
one but then you have also the the last
one the stitchers with github dot you
there is a lot of resources in there and
also real wall examples because at the
end what I want with this talk is that
you feel empowered to do your own vs
code telemetry for example which is so
complex thing is when you share your
connection with another fella in a
different part of the wall and you can
see how your you type in how is he
typing and so on it's a fancy machine
and then also does anyone knows what it
is
correct Marsh Robert it was kinda easy
if you've been hearing Wednesday because
they'd be the spoil my my picture that
but this is this is a really good
example and for all of you that were in
here on Wednesday
basically the marsh robber was was
because it's working already
I find the same machine so I guess that
is the best software engineers in the
world decided that they are going to
invest the gazillion billion trillion
whatever of dollars to send a
robot to another planet you only have
one shot and you cannot it up and
they pick up the fancy machines to do so
I get that's the best real-world example
you can have that's basically it
remember I'm independent contractor if
you need a fighter you can call me thank
you
[Applause]